o latitude de quem fala é o dar que
sejam muito bem vindos já é mais um
vídeo e eu não sei porque o sushi
comissões têm que tomar vai né
vamos lá então o que interessa pessoal
que experimentar e que este dré do off
nos jogos rita e foi logo que olhar o
que dizem ser um dos jogos mais
ditadores este é um pouco antigo e tal
mas eu acho que sem um amplo leque então
mas jesus tesouro não é tão mais voltar
aqui então vamos lá aqui para os nossos
jogos 32 um labirinto pronto tá tá tá tá
eu juntar um logo o pior e que podem
juntar membros de meu tio meu avô vai
dar conta do desespero que está a passar
perto do ombro que isto irá expor também
texto único caminho que entende agora é
o que eu acho que tudo que há no mínimo
estranha a uma taxa só não quer lutar
não é do advogado
o estado é um bicho atrás meu pessoal
vai julgar aquilo que é uma gárgula o
campo que a música de fundo declarou
ayew tac tac é um bicho meu eu tava se
irão thomas que fosse bola ajuda
não vamos fugir fosse oferecer o que ele
vai ganhar o ouro
não não não me metia em mim por favor
quando tentam a sorte ao estudo
estava realmente não não não não não não
fosse não ser por uma cultura de
produtos de páscoa uru
como estará o peito enquanto o ladrão
ainda posso fazer por trás por trás do
que naquilo que eu era muito
ai meu deus o que se passou aqui meu é
meu
cansado de bruxa
outra vez um rato está muito sensível já
está muito velho
quando cheguei porque uma coisa guardada
esqueleto esqueleto cargos 500 meu único
tom já tem luz já tem luz faz lá por
onde eu preciso encontrar mais óleo meu
orgulho fui quem curte estigma malucos
mil
o bahia por sua vez meu estilo é tomar
luke eu tava um bicho de gigante o que
quer aquilo era uma carraça ser um cão
meu a ela tá vilela tab por funciona
para o seu país não me lembro da minha
mãe gritou para que a tonelada cabeça
grande e possui uma marca por onde meu
deus eu estou cansada cansada não
consigo não consigo corre a mãe corre
por ele criado abre uma nova namorada
ela ainda contou ainda que o pai a minha
vida a minha vida o que é preciso é
preciso lhe dá mole onde tá tudo ok ok
então chama podem fazer uma aposta com
deus meu deus pessoal é muita pressão
aqui meu sempre assim da luz rumo e foi
muito bom ouvir que passos s80 bicho e
do outro
eu vou abrir a mesma fosse ele foge a pé
e não tem pleno domínio porque bebeu
porque depois que sua esposa foi
excluído nuclei porque estava chegando
só tem um esqueleto isto é muito
estranho no pleito e vamos virar aqui
algumas à direita
confira aqui houve mais lá em cima da
cama em que os embargos meu tal mas é
gago as portas pra cima
o circuito future marcar a minha e não
encostou a cara lá minha meu espanto por
o meu ok dok uma porta vou ver estou mas
futebol é coisa mais simples que vi aqui
pra assustar conseguiu mas estar meu
aquela portaria globo né não
depois porque lá não sei que eu tenho
que fazer o que quiser escapar do
labirinto e apanhar mais moedas de ouro
se apanhar algum mapa ou outro mapa não
sai
olha quem saída nem anos terá fim no
mapa é o fim do mapa aqui ao outro qual
é o texto aponta esta nem digo que esta
é aquecida é que saímos então sugiro que
queimamos o google books como esqueletos
que se conseguir filhos da mãe conseguiu
escapar daqui e passar este jogo até o
fim mas o jogo deixando cansado eu sinto
fisicamente cansado parece que estava em
uma goleira fugiu do povoado não sei
explicar mas focos de febre o tal
pessoal cores sempre que tenho uma
oportunidade por mim tem com certeza
esse foi um dos piores jogos de terror
que os games jogos rio e pessoal a sério
tipo brutal cinco estrelas e vamos ter
um jogo porque assim fico mais na folha
voz meu mas é espero que vocês tenham
gostado deste negócio aí que favorito
fiquem bem r 6 e até a próxima